بالطبع جزء من السبب الذي جعل
مجموعة fogger قد ضحت بالكثير من الحياة في
هذا الأمر لأنهم يريدون الحصول على
نصر صحيح ، لذا فهي مدينة صغيرة
وقد تكون غير ذات صلة من الناحية الاستراتيجية ولكن
بعد ذلك يكون لديهم انتصار ويمكنهم
استخدام ذلك pagosian الذي يدير
يمكن لمجموعة فاغنر استخدام ذلك لبوتين ليقول إنني
يجب أن أكون الرجل المسؤول بشكل
صحيح ، يجب أن أكون الرجل البارز على
عكس الآخرين في الصناعة العسكرية
بما في ذلك وزير الدفاع الروسي
سيرجي شويغو الذي يقاتل أيضًا من
أجل السلطة هنا رأينا
shoegu اليوم أتفقد القوات الروسية وأنا أشعر
بالفضول عندما تعلم أننا
رأينا الإخفاقات التي سمعناها عن
الجيش الروسي هنا لمجموعة Wagner
ولكن ما الذي تنظر إليه الآن
لمعرفة ما إذا كان جيش shoigu سيذهب
حقًا تمامًا  الكهف والانهيار
أه أعتقد أنهم في النهاية
سينهارون وينهارون ، وأصبح من
المرجح يومًا بعد يوم أن ترى shoigu في
بيئة نظيفة جدًا تقدم المعادن
لقد كان الرجل الذي هو ب
المسؤولون عن الجيش الروسي على مدى السنوات
العشر الماضية بالإضافة إلى المراوغة العامة ،
فهم مسؤولون عن
الفشل الذريع لحكم الكليبتوقراطية
عن الفساد داخل الجيش
الذي تسبب في نقص التدريب ونقص
مهارات الجندي وهزيمة في
ساحة المعركة بحيث تكون المنافسة بين
shoigu و garasimov مع uh pergrosin
قائد مجموعة Wagner على
الجانب الآخر مجرد شيء رائع من
رجل عسكري محترف مثلي
لمشاهدته لأنه مجرد كوميديا ​​من
الأخطاء ويظهر مدى الفساد ليس
فقط الجيش  ما هو إلا
النظام الحكومي الروسي بأكمله ، ولهذا السبب
لن يقاتل الجنود من أجل هذا النوع
من الإجراءات ، من الصعب جدًا على
المحترف أن يشرح ما
نراه هو مدى سوء إضافة
الجيش الروسي إلى الحكومة الروسية كما هو معروض
في ساحة المعركة